SPEAKER Hello.
Today we're excited to announce
the beta of Security Health
Analytics, a security product
that integrates into Cloud
Security Command Center.
Security Health Analytics helps
you identify misconfiguration
and compliance violations in
your Google Cloud Platform
resources and take action.
Security Command Center now
has a new Vulnerabilities tab.
When you click the
Vulnerabilities tab,
you will be taken
to a dashboard that
summarizes vulnerability
findings identified
by Security Health Analytics.
If you haven't yet enabled
Security Health Analytics,
the first time you
land on this page,
you will be presented
with a message indicating
that you need to enable Security
Health Analytics in order
to see vulnerabilities.
You can click Manage
Security Sources,
which links to the
Security Sources Management
page, where you can enable
Security Health Analytics.
After you enable Security
Health Analytics,
a preliminary scan
is kicked off.
Within a few minutes,
findings, our word for results,
will begin to be
published and available
in the Vulnerabilities
dashboard.
At this point, you can visit
the Vulnerabilities tab again,
and you will be presented
with the misconfigurations
that Security Health
Analytics has detected.
Misconfigurations are presented
as a table of recommendations.
These recommendations are
sorted by their severity.
Each recommendation
is associated
with an individual finding type.
For example, the firewall
rules recommendation
is associated with the
open firewall finding type.
The Active column
shows the number
of currently active findings.
The Status column shows
the current status
of the detector that
produced the finding.
If you mouse over
the Status icon,
a hint is displayed that
indicates when the scan last
finished running.
The Benchmark column
currently shows
which CIS benchmark each
recommendation is associated
with.
For example, open RDP port
is associated with CIS GCP
foundation benchmark 3.7.
Sometimes you'll have a lot
of projects, many of which
are test projects.
It is important to be able
to show active findings
over a subset of projects.
For these use cases, the
Vulnerabilities dashboard
has a projects filter.
You can click on the Plus
button to add a project
to the projects filter.
Let's select API Test.
You can add more than one
project to the project's filter
and see all of the active
findings in either project.
Here we can see
96 active findings
for open firewall across
the project's API test
and buckets without
object versioning.
You can click on Open
Firewall, and you'll
be taken to the Findings
tab, with the correct filters
applied so that you can see
the individual open firewall
findings for just the
projects selected.
If you click on one
of the findings,
you will be presented
with a Finding Detail
page that provides an overview
of the problem, as well
as a step-by-step
remediation guide.
From here you can click directly
on the firewall rule, which
opens the page in another tab.
This allows you to go
back to the previous tab
to see the remaining
instructions.
Start using Security
Command Center today
and enable Security
Health Analytics
to help prevent
misconfigurations
and compliance violations
in your GCP projects.
Thanks.